Speaker 1: Student loan payments have
been suspended once again by the Biden
administration as they have announced that
they're going to push back when people will
have to start making payments on their bills yet
again. The moratorium started in spring of 2020,
of course, with the COVID 19 pandemic and the
plan that President Biden unveiled earlier this
year was that in exchange for the $10,000 of
student loan forgiveness. More if you got Pell
Grants that they would bring back the payments
at the start of 2023. But then we learned that
there were these Republican efforts to challenge
Biden's executive order to forgive the debt,
and two of the lawsuits ended up succeeding, at
least for now, putting on halt the Biden debt
relief plan and leaving millions of Americans in
limbo. The Biden administration is saying that
they will resume payments either halfway through
2023 or shortly after the courts ideally allow
his executive order to stand. So depending
on what the courts decide to do is when you
may have to start making payments again if that
type of thing applies to you. Biden is rightfully
playing politics with this, of course, saying
that if Republicans are going to tie up what
he wants to do in the courts, he's going to use
his power to make sure that, at least for now,
people with student loans are benefiting from
his presidency. It would also be kind of strange,
unfair if someone who has, let's say, $9,000
worth of student loan debt all of a sudden has
to start making payments on that balance again,
even though they thought that they wouldn't have
to pay it at all. They thought it was all going
to get forgiven. And now they still don't even
know if it's going to ultimately get forgiven.
As I mentioned, there are two cases holding up
the debt relief. The first came to us on November
10th after a right wing federal judge in Texas put
a halt on the debt relief plan because they were
going to hear out the case of two borrowers who
didn't qualify for the debt relief. The plaintiffs
were, of course, backed by conservative groups.
And then shortly after that, we heard from the
U.S. Court of Appeals in Missouri. They granted
an injunction by six red states against the debt
relief plan. That one has to do with whether Biden
has the authority to do this as president or if
he needs congressional approval. And I got to say,
it pains me to say this, but there is a good
chance, at least a decent chance that the
courts will end up striking this down outright,
because the legal justification that Biden is
using to forgive the debt is kind of on shaky
grounds, like the basis is the 2003 Heroes Act,
which allows the Education Department leeway
for rules surrounding student loans if there's
a war or national emergency. In this case, the
national emergency is being cited as COVID 19,
which no doubt would have been successful maybe
back in 2020, 2021, during the worst parts of
the pandemic. But the courts, and especially
these right wing courts, may say that, okay,
well, we're beyond COVID as an emergency. It's one
thing to have a pause on payments during a crisis,
especially when people can't work. It's a
different thing altogether to forgive debt
going forward. And so you really need Congress to
pass this. The president can't do this on their
own. There's also the question about whether this
will hurt Republicans if they're able to torpedo
this thing, because you may imagine that's there
going to be plenty of Republican constituents
who would stand to benefit from student loan
forgiveness. Maybe they'll look the other way.
Maybe they'll say that they didn't want it in
the first place and it was unfair or whatever
that type of thing happens. You never know with
these Republican constituents. It's also a long
time before they have to vote against it. It'll
be another two years before the 2024 elections,
so maybe there won't be any sort of consequences,
but hopefully it doesn't come to that. Hopefully
this debt relief plan is going to be able to stand
up because $10,000, up to $20,000, that can really
do a lot of good for a lot of people. But let
me know what you think. Will this be allowed
to stand up? And if it is struck down, will
Republicans have to pay a political price for it?